so what did Jews believe happens when
you die um I think it's like we believe
in heaven but we don't necessarily
believe in Hell so I guess it's like
everyone goes to heaven doesn't make
sense you ordered a sandwich on Passover
oops you're not having any locks on your
bagel I don't really like blocking I've
never heard of that I guess it's like
you live on through your grandkids or
maybe just your kids you know I suppose
ceaseless from wash right is that a ham
sandwich
yeah it's ham and cheese ham and cheese
oh my I just this is that the key part
from my bar mitzvah so you're Jewish but
you don't you're not a practicing Jew oh
that's so sweet
is this Samara shove-it a couple months
ago when I was home for Christmas
Christmas
hello Han you melech ha-olam I shared a
show in the middle of it seedy bar new
Jeff for Mitzvah no I chose not to do
that he chose not to have a huge party
with all your friends there DJ catered
food what are you giving Bernie give him
like 20 bucks you don't know about 1836
the street or in a green glass
Greenblatt's yes so you know about
Jewish delis but you don't know about
the Jewish afterlife I'm thinking I may
name my son after you how can you name
your son after me I might even Dead Yet
this is so good I get you're a goober
you're still seeing that shiksa what the
Gentile girl we broke up oh that's good
hey mom hey mom how you guys ever how
are you mom uncle Seymour says hi
no I'm not hurt I'm just on a date yes
he lost weight she tell her I'm Jewish
I'm gonna tell her you do yes she's
Jewish
I've gained weight yeah well you too hey
mom
all right mom okay I gotta get off okay
all right all right so you're like more
Jew it really just Jew ish just juju ish
yeah Happy Hanukkah yeah man make a wish
and what a Hanukkah it's been
Oh